- It is 11 AM, on a
work day, let's do this.
(driving rock beat)
- I'm already getting an
Adam Levine vibe from this.
- Adam Levine, really?
- I don't know why.
- I'm interested
- Cheers.
(glasses clink)
- Mmm.
- Not terrible.
- That's like, get you
fired up for a fight.
- No, if somebody brought
you this as a shot,
- Yeah
- You could finish it
- Right
- and not throw up.
- I want to say it's Justin Timberlake.
- Mmm
- I'm gonna go with J.T.
- Jay Z!
- Ahhhh!
- Oh, he's fancy.
- Doesn't this taste a
little bit like Jay Z?
I could imagine Jay Z
- Yeah
- sipping on this after Beyonce's
yelled at him a little bit.
- This smells like some B.S.
(laughs)
- This smells like straight sugar.
- I think this is Nicki
even before I taste it
because it looks elegant.
- Mmm!
- Woah, what the fuck?
- That is way too sweet.
- There's no category that this excels in.
- This tastes like an apple crayon.
- This tastes like
Nicki Minaj's lip gloss.
- If this is Kanye I'm gonna cry.
- It certainly reminds me
of the queen Nicki Minaj.
- Yeah!
(laughs)
- Nicki, no, you know better.
- Now, knowing that it's Nicki Minaj,
I definitely like it more.
- Oh, smells like ranch dressing!
- It does smell like ranch dressing.
- This smells like tequila.
- Ach.
- Wow
- Ooh.
- This is great, it's really
smooth, it's flavorful.
- I would be definitely
drinking this at a pool party.
- Which head would you like,
- Woah.
(laughs)
- This is a visionary liquor.
Kanye's a visionary man.
- That's a face you make when
you've been drinking tequila.
- Ohhh
- OK
- Justin, your tequila is a lot like you.
It looks white, but then there's
a nice little kick at the end.
- Justin just does everything right.
- Oh
- Oh it's fruity.
- Yeah this is gonna suck.
- It smells like a Yankee Candle.
- You know what this smells like exactly?
- What?
- A Push Pop.
- Yes!
- Ugh, terrible after taste!
(coughs)
- Tastes a bit watermeloney.
- This tastes like the equivalent
of seeing a 14 year old
kid smoking a cigarette.
- I hope it's P. Diddy,
it would be hilarious
if this was P. Diddy's alcohol.
- Funky and sugary with
just a hint of spice,
I'm going Nicki Minaj.
- Are you serious?
- Are you kidding me?
Woah, what?
- Diddy would make, he makes
these drinks for women.
- You know what, this was
probably inspired by J Lo.
- Oh that is, it's like
feet and rubbing alcohol.
- Ugh
- Ugh.
- Smells like college party vodka.
- Ahhh.
- It has a sweetness to it that
my face would indicate otherwise.
- Normally vodka is a chore,
but this is like, all right.
- I feel like it's
either Kanye or Pharrell.
- I would have to agree,
it's gotta be Yeezy.
- It's gotta be Yeezy.
- What?
- What, Dan Akroyd?
- Look at Dan, he's never been with
a cooler group of people
in his entire life though.
- I don't know why I thought
these would be different
from normal liquors, like oh
they're celebrity liquors.
No this just looks like whiskey,
it has a celebrity face on it.
- [Man] The only occasion
where it would make sense
for me to drink these in the future
would be if the actual celebrity
was pouring it themselves.
- [Man] Yes.
If I had a lot of money, I
would make my own alcohol too.